we should mention the shooting is also
reigniting the gun debate on Capitol
Hill in the wake of other mass shootings
bills to mandate background checks
prevent stalkers from buying guns and
banned so-called bump stocks stalled in
Congress Nancy Cordes spoke with a group
of retiring Republican lawmakers for
Sunday's Face the Nation about
congressional inaction she joins us from
the set of Face the Nation Nancy good
morning good morning about two dozen
Republicans have already announced that
they're not going to be running for
re-election and some say that they've
grown frustrated with the gridlock that
reigns even after tragic events like
this one i sat down with four departing
lawmakers Jeff Flake Ileana ros-lehtinen
charlie dent and Edie who said Congress
does need to be doing more to combat
mass violence it's tearing the country
apart and I think it's a real
opportunity for the Republican Party to
step up and and be be leaders in this
debate and we're just going to continue
this throughout the school year it is it
is impossible to deal with this kind of
grief on a daily basis I'm incredibly
frustrated that we haven't moved
legislation to prevent bump stocks
why has your leadership not moved bump
stock legislation I thought everyone
agreed on I think that the thought here
is that ATF is going to take those
actions on their own but from my
standpoint as a co-sponsor of
legislation to move something off the
House floor I think we ought to mandate
it senator when you talk about
immigration mass violence opioids has
Congress lost its ability to solve big
problems you know it'd be hard to argue
that we haven't we've had a hard time
coming together and it does not appear
that that is going to change anytime
soon yesterday I asked House Speaker
Paul Ryan whether law enforcement
officials should be able to confiscate
weapons from mentally ill people who
like this young man expressed an
interest in violence the speaker said as
he has asked their many mass shootings
that it isn't time to jump to
conclusions and if there are gaps in the
background check system that those
should be addressed at some point Norah
it's a good question because the sheriff
was asking
just that right the other day from
lawmakers let me ask you to Nancy
because as it looks like they may not be
able to get anything done on this issue
what about immigration well it
completely fell apart in the Senate this
week none of the bipartisan or
Republican plans were able to get to 60
votes and so we now turn to the house
where the planet's most likely to get a
vote is a Republican plan that does
provide protections for these so-called
dreamers but also includes a lot of
tough new immigration reforms that are
going to fall flat with Senate Democrats
so the path forward for these hundreds
of thousands of so-called dreamers is
really in limbo right now with the daca
program set to expire in a few weeks
we're gonna get into all of that this
weekend on Face the Nation with Democrat
Chris Coons and Republican Tim Scott see
if there's anything at this point that
Congress can do sounds like you have a
good line up there Nancy thank you and
you can see more of Nancy's interview on
Face the Nation this Sunday